me and you are like this today oh my
it's definitely you don't take avocados
yeah common for actors to find love on
set it's also fairly common that they'd
break up and have to continue filming
like nothing happened let's get into
some of these number one friendship
turned romantic on this one Harry Styles
and Olivia Wilde met on the set of don't
worry darling back in September 2020 and
apparently the chemistry was immediate
their co-stars knew something was bound
to happen even before they did everyone
saw it coming during breaks he hasn't
been able to stay away and visited her
trailer an interesting moment for Harry
was shooting the intimate scenes where
he gets to be directed by Olivia Wilde
who both directed and acted in the film
surprisingly it wasn't as awkward as you
would think I had a wonderful experience
being directed by Olivia though he found
the scenes awkward to shoot regardless
but shooting it with Olivia behind the
lens made it a lot easier being able to
trust your director is a gift boys and
their toys at least we know they're
getting work done number two these Cobra
Kai stars have quite the history you
guys are clearly like super good friends
you know so I want to know any funny oh
the funny thing about their relationship
is that they've known each other since
they were teenagers with Jacob being
really good friends with Peyton's
brother the two first met in 2015 on the
set of Disney's The Swamp but it wasn't
until years later that they actually got
together they ended up confirming their
relationship in March 2022. Jacob
confessed to TMZ we've been dating for a
while I've never dated anyone I've
worked with before this is almost trial
by fire number three everyone's favorite
Hollywood couple but it took them five
years to actually come out as that Tom
Holland and Zendaya first worked
together on Spider-Man homecoming and
were found to be the subject of romance
rumors ever since it wasn't until 2019
that their on-screen characters shared
their first kiss setting the fandom into
a frenzy months later Zendaya and Tom
were spotted kissing in a car thus
confirming the rumors of their
relationship they've been going strong
and are a consistent pillar of support
in each other's lives with Tom playing a
pivotal role for Zendaya when depicting
those tough scenes in Euphoria I think
it's great to have that support and love
around you because you need that Zendaya
shared when asked about how Holland
pulls her out of the dark moments as Rue
this isn't an easy job so it's good to
have that to free you up from it every
now and then number four the Riverdale
cast are no strangers to off-screen
chemistry who is Charles Melton David my
girlfriend and what kind of question is
that people
Camilla Mendes and Charles Melton who
play Veronica and Reggie announced their
relationship on Instagram in 2018 but
ended up calling it quits shortly after
their one year anniversary however they
did promise their fans that they would
keep things cool and professional
between them for the sake of the show
number five more behind the scenes
Riverdale romance Cole Sprouse and Lily
Reinhardt met Mall filming the CW Show's
first season they began dating shortly
after in July 2017 two years later in
July 2019 it had been made public
knowledge that the pair had split up
they did get back together shortly after
but broke up for a second time in may
2020. they did have to continue working
together even still portraying an
on-screen couple despite the assumptions
that they were not on speaking terms
outside work number six we got a great
album out of this one Olivia Rodrigo and
Joshua Bassett first met on the set of
High School Musical the musical of the
series in 2019 from which their
on-screen chemistry transferred over
into real life with and speculating a
romantic relationship in 2020 Olivia
told the LA times about one of her
experiences working with Joshua where he
improvised a line he said remember that
one time we wrote a song and we didn't
know if anybody would like it that one
made me cry because I just remembered
sharing those memories with him I love
him so much he's my best friend it was
like I wasn't acting they ended up
splitting sometime around 2020 with
multiple songs being written by both
Partners about the other resulting in
them not being on speaking terms for at
least a year in July 2022 they amicably
reunited on the red carpet number 7.
Machine Gun Kelly is a musician yes but
he's also been in a fair share of films
do you remember him in nerve what about
his film good morning anyone know the
number to 9-1-1 he and Megan Fox met on
the set of midnight in the switchgrass
in 2020 and have been together ever
since people started speculating when
she starred in his music video Bloody
Valentine back in May of 2020. what is
my hidden talent
number eight this one is definitely a
little awkward Joey King and Jacob
alordy met on the set of Netflix's the
kissing booth in 2017 which resulted in
a whirlwind romance that lasted until
2019 but while yes Joey and Jacob's real
life relationship was over I'll and
Noah's relationship was just beginning
the kissing booth was so successful that
it not only garnered the kissing booth 2
to follow but as luck would have it the
kissing booth 3 which premiered in 2021
that's a lot of time spent with your ex
when asked if she would ever date
another co-star no I couldn't number
nine stranger things have happened on
the set of stranger things Charlie
Heaton and Natalia Dyer met while
filming season one of stranger things
hey
hey
apparently the chemistry was super
apparent before they'd even landed their
roles Matt Duffer co-creator of the show
told GQ about their audition process the
first audition we did a chemistry read
with Heaton and Natalya and Sparks were
flying number 10 from small roles and
stranger things to starring in Outer
Banks Chase strokes and Madeleine Klein
met in 2019 right before season one
started shooting with Madeleine
confirming their romantic relationship
on Instagram in June 2020. by December
2021 the pair seemed to split up with
both parties deleting most of the
Instagram photos of the other though
they continued to work on Outer Banks
together number 11 just a bit of
awkwardness before the sequel these two
X-Men Stars couldn't make it work off
camera but still delivered not one but
two Stellar movies after their breakup
Nick always said whenever I yelled at
him as always Jennifer Lawrence and
Nicholas Holt met on the set of X-Men
first Class and continued to date just
before filming the sequel X-Men Days of
Future Past they were able to complete
that film and join each other back on
set for the third installment of the
franchise X-Men apocalypse see like his
like smile flickering and I'm like why
are you smiling and he's like because
you sound like your dad number 12. an
on-screen couple turns into real-life
husband and wife kit Harrington and Rose
Leslie met on the set of Game of Thrones
and apparently fell in love during the
show's second season in 2012. I met my
wife in the show so in that way it gave
me my future family and my life from
here on in they were on again off again
until their engagement in 2017. they
were married the following year in
Scotland I was like I've always keep
banging on about Rose but I was giving
her a kiss let them at the airport then
she's leaving for months and this guy
walks up and I went no no number 13.
Sparks Fly on the set of Edward
Scissorhands Johnny Depp and Winona
Ryder were one of the most famous
couples in Hollywood throughout the
duration of their relationship from 1989
to 1993. Johnny Depp was one of the
first and definitely not one of last
people to get their partner's name
tattooed on them he got Winona Forever
on his arm could make it wino forever
for instance he did eventually get the
tattoo changed to wino forever number
14. we really hate to bring up this era
but I feel bad because I don't feel like
kissing you Twilight stars Kristen
Stewart and Robert Pattinson started
dating while shooting the first film in
the legendary vampire franchise they
even broke up and got back together a
few times before breaking up for good
right before Breaking Dawn Part 2 came
out though the breakup wasn't easy they
still have great camaraderie and Kristen
Stewart still speaks highly about Rob
he's a Charming guy I mean he's really
number 15. The Vampire Diaries is full
of complicated love stories on screen
and off Nina Dobrev who plays the
indecisive Elena couldn't decide between
the two Salvatore Brothers Damon and
Stefan but off-screen she definitely had
her mind made up after meeting on set in
2010 Nina tried really hard to hold back
her feelings for co-star Ian Somerhalder
I didn't want to be dating one of my
co-stars my goal on that show was to be
professional but sometimes he can't help
who you have a connection with and you
can only invite it for so long which I
did for a really really long time they
dated for three years ultimately ending
their relationship in 2013 but continued
to work together and portray an
on-screen couple until 2015. there are
so many love stories on and off the
screen it really is hard to keep track
who is your favorite on-screen romance
turned into a real life couple let us
know in the comments